here's what would happen if the
Megalodon fought the Titanoboa titanoboa
stocked its prey by hiding in water or
between trees and waiting for the
perfect moment to strike if the
Megalodon swam right under the snake
well the Titanoboa would attack it
before the shark knew what hit it it
would sink its curved teeth into the
shark coil itself tightly around its
prey and squeeze hard trying to choke
the life out of the Megalodon but sharks
don't have lungs they've got gills
titanoboa needs to crush the Megalodon
and collapse its organs or block its
Gill openings or the big snake could
drag the shark up onto land in deeper
waters the Megalodon could use a
high-speed assault and attack from
underneath in moments those razor sharp
teeth would split the snake in two in
the end it would all depend on who gets
the first strike because